George Floyd six-year-old daughter
Gianna already knows the impact her dad
has had on the world protests against
police brutality are happening all over
the US and the world after Floyd a 46
year old black man in Minneapolis died
when a police officer pressed his knee
into his neck for more than eight
minutes in a touching new video shared
to Instagram Gianna sits on the
shoulders of her dad's longtime friend
former NBA star Steven Jackson smiles
ear to ear
and beams with pride Jackson shared the
clip on his account writing that's right
Gigi daddy changed the world
George Floyd the name of change the
former basketball star also shared a
GoFundMe page for Gianna which surpassed
its 500 thousand dollar goal in just one
day this thing won't be easy this thing
will be easy
and to everybody that know me I'm all
the way in Jackson is a longtime friend
of Floyd's he even said they referred to
themselves as twins
prior to his tragic death Jackson shared
a screen grab of the GoFundMe page on
Instagram and wrote in the caption don't
worry twin on my soul I got Gigi know
that I am my brother's keeper and I got
a lot of brothers adding rest easy twins
I don't have a lot to say because I
can't get my words together right now
on Tuesday Gianna's mom Roxie Washington
spoke out making a tearful statement
with her daughter by her side at
Minneapolis City Hall
grow up graduate he will never walk down
if it's the problem she's having it she
needs a dad
she does not have a bed anymore
Jackson Washington and Floyd's little
girl sat down with CNN on Tuesday for a
tear-filled interview my wife cited I'm
saying my name on TV she wanted to know
how he that hey the only thing that I
can tell is